Lena lighter and diabetes-free Kieran
lost nearly three and a half Stone in a
supervised diet of soups and shakes
containing just 800 calories a day that
was eight years ago and by watching his
weight his blood sugar is still under
control without the need for medication
I suppose for me it was a chance to
reboot so when I went to the doctors and
they mentioned it to me I wasn't in a
good place you know a lot of very much
overweight diet was horrendous and I was
just in a dime with spiral so gave me a
chance to reboot
a new study shows for the first time
that people with a type 2 form of
diabetes which is closely related to
obesity can permanently reverse the
condition if they lose weight and keep
it off the diet will now be prescribed
by the NHS at a cost of little more than
a thousand pounds
losing weight helps to restore the
normal function of the pancreas
stabilizing blood sugar levels this new
research shows the benefits can be
lifelong keep the weight off and there's
no need for pills and injections
including insulin
four and a half million people in the UK
are thought to be living with type 2
diabetes another 2 million are at risk
every week diabetes results in more than
180 amputations
770 strokes and almost 600 heart attacks
and the NHS spends around 10 billion
pounds a year about 10 percent of its
Budget on treating type 2 diabetes and
its complications
so many people who sit at home and
perhaps join the gym after Christmas
begin to go to the gym once or twice a
week and then that quickly diminishes so
what we've got to try to encourage
people is we've got to advertise that
weight loss has the biggest impact on
our lives and I don't think many people
actually appreciate that
losing weight can be tough and a new
appetite suppressing drug is available
on the NHS to people who are clinically
obese for Keith diet alone was enough
and dodging diabetes is all the
motivation he needs to watch the
calories
Thomas More Sky News